great movies are like a conversation
filmmakers are communicating with the
audience sure but they're also
communicating with each other or
sometimes themselves often directors
just can't help themselves and let
everyone eavesdrop on this cinematic
conversations here are hidden Easter
eggs that reference other movies Toy
Story while trapped at SIDS house Buzz
Lightyear experiences a small
existential crisis and starts wondering
does that carpet seem familiar that's
because it was lifted from the Overlook
Hotel in the shining while we appreciate
the nod to a Stanley Kubrick classic
we're happy Pixar stopped short of
showing us creepy twins or elevators
full of blood Zootopia toward the end of
Zootopia duke weaselton is selling
bootleg DVDs on the street in addition
to the fact that duke weaselton zhn aim
is a reference to frozen's Duke of
weselton
the DVDs he's selling our animal
versions of Disney films like big hero 6
tangled wreck-it Ralph and more does
anyone else really want to actually see
these movies considering big hero 6 is
billed as the best animated film on this
DVD it's got to be good right Captain
America the Winter Soldier Captain
America the Winter Soldier boasts some
super spy action featuring Nick Fury
played by samuel l.jackson he's probably
still most famous for his role in pulp
fiction as Jules Winnfield
Jules quoted a Bible verse right before
gunning down a man Ezekiel 25:17
the path of the righteous man is beset
on all sides by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men part
of the same court is on Fury's headstone
after he's presumed dead
rango in this Johnny Depp film Rango
gets into some trouble and tumbles
around on the highway in the desert
before he gets the safety Rango ends up
pancaked on the windshield of a Cadillac
Eldorado
being driven by the characters from Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas starring
Johnny Depp the kids must have gotten a
kick out of this because children just
love Hunter s Thompson coming to America
coming to America stars Eddie Murphy as
a young African Prince intent on
experiencing what America has to offer
during his travels he encounters some
down-on-their-luck brothers who could
use a buck or two these bombs just
happened to be the Duke brothers the
antagonists from Murphy's earlier hit
Trading Places after going broke in the
previous movie it's nice to see Prince
Akeem lending a hand Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory in Tim Burton's
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
we find out that Charlie's dad makes
very little money screwing on the caps
of smilax toothpaste at a factory but
did you realize that we've heard of
Smile X before way back in Tim Burton's
Batman from 1999 The Polar Express
Robert Zemeckis directed the Polar
Express a CGI Christmas movie starring
Tom Hanks he also directed the Back to
the Future series featuring one of the
most iconic time machines ever the
DeLorean remember what makes the
DeLorean work that's right
the flux capacitor well it turns out
that's how the Polar Express gets the
north pole so fast predator 2 while
watching predator 2 you can spot a skull
in the trophy room that looks pretty
familiar in case you're wondering yes it
belongs to a xenomorph from the alien
movies and its presence is only natural
because aliens and predators live in a
shared universe and it's always hunting
season for predators still the better
hope they never try to hunt
it's wabbit season not leave on fire
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Easter Egg
was the biggest surprise to you